I'm lucky in a lot of ways I never
imagined that I'd be doing this like
many of you I've been playing video
games for as long as I can remember I
don't think that me and my brother would
be as close as we are if it weren't for
the games we played together and now
suddenly I've been given this huge
following of people that watch me play
games and that's intimidating I want to
believe that video games can change the
world I want to believe that it can
bring people together all across the
globe of different backgrounds and
ideals and I'm finally starting to
realize that you guys have given me the
opportunity to do that right here on
this channel I uploaded my first video
to my first channel on April 4th 2012 at
10:30 6 p.m.
and now just over ten months later I
have over a hundred thousand subscribers
I have a lot of people that I want to
thank because I didn't get here alone
I want to thank yamimash Mangum inks
cinnamon toast can and most importantly
I want to thank all of you because
without you I would be nowhere
it's your support your work and your
sharing that has gotten me to this point
you guys and gals out there are the
reason why this channel is having any
success right now because this is your
channel as much as it is mine
so thank you guys so much I've never
cared about anything as much as I care
about this channel it's the reason why I
get up in the morning and the reason why
stay ibly I just want to work on it and
I want to make content for you guys and
I want to do this for a long time and I
want to do more I want to do better
videos I want to do bigger things I want
to make my own stuff I believe that
anyone can and you guys have given me an
amazing opportunity and I'm never gonna
forget that and I'm never gonna forget
Who I am
or why I do this so thank you guys from
the bottom of my heart thank you so much
you have changed my life now I'm always
gonna be grateful
so thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye